the leia hope and show
[Music]
sponsored by step finance
your go to d5 portfolio manager on
solana
luna if you're just getting into bitcoin
it's the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to another
episode of the leia hill pan show
powered by the vc firm icon plus capital
as usual this is also sponsored by block
fight so check out block by um you can
actually get amazing interest rates i
think right now on stable coins it's
around 9 which could be the most
competitive so i've actually left the
link for you in the description and in
the comment section i use them i like
them so definitely go check them out so
today is going to be a little
interesting actually um because i'm
speaking with somebody that i don't know
that well usually this doesn't happen uh
so i'm quite excited and it's going to
be very um nft based so our nfts are
bubble um i think it's pretty hot right
now so i'm excited to to chat with him
so he's sort of come out of nowhere in
the last eight months um he's a big
youtuber um he's built a huge community
and he's sort of known as a little bit
of a nft expert says bring him in it is
matt's crypto hey matt how you doing
how's it going thanks for having me on
i'm good how you doing how you doing
i'm great i can't complain with nfts
right now things are going pretty well
yeah i'm really excited to chat with you
because like i said we don't know each
other that well so this is just going to
be
learning about each other understanding
the nft space um
but before we go into the nft space i
want to know a bit about you because you
sort of popped out of nowhere in the
last eight months on youtube you've
built an amazing an amazingly engaged
audience like it's pretty crazy so
talk to me about that where did you come
from
uh well i mean i guess for people that
are you know in the crypto space yes i
did pop up eight months ago but
i i've been on youtube for uh 12 years
actually so this is not my first rodeo
when it comes to youtube channels so
that's that's probably in part why the
channel is doing so well i have i have
an idea of how to make a youtube channel
work but um
yeah so like two years ago i got into
crypto um one of my buddies runs a a
mining company in north america one of
the biggest ones actually
um and he's been you know i was living
with him for five years throughout
college
and uh so i started to get more
interested in it one thing led to
another uh started getting into all
coins and then naturally progressed to
nfts and and here we are made a channel
about it and it's doing quite well
so i actually didn't know that you'd um
i mean i could see now in the background
but i didn't know all of this um about
your background so tell me what other
youtube channels have you built and i
want the full story um
that's i've probably done over a dozen
channels in in the last 12 years um
there's a lot of my main one was a
gaming channel a lot of call of duty uh
you know shooters first person shooters
um and then i've done like trending
channels like top 10 channels
i've done animation channels
um i've kind of done a little bit of
everything and then i also consult for
other channels um all different kinds a
lot of gaming uh some animation but
you know a bunch of different youtube
channels so i have a pretty good
understanding of how youtube and um you
know how to grow how to grow a channel
you know organically
um
but yeah that's that's pretty much it
i think everyone wants to know how to
grow a channel organically like what are
your number one tips tell me i need to
grow what are your number one um
well i actually asked you before we
started the show why do you prefer to do
these live uh because yeah i think i
actually think they would do a lot
better if you did them as
standalone videos even though we
recorded you know we pre-record it live
yeah i think it will do better if you if
you actually
edited out the best parts and um you
know added some graphics and stuff like
that i think we do actually a lot better
okay we'll have to talk about that after
the show yeah i just i like doing it
live i like it it just feels
natural it's fun it's a lot it's a lot
more fun it's definitely uh a little bit
easier to do from a you know creator
perspective like it takes a lot less
time right um and you have like a great
looking show here so it looks good
either way for your end but i i do think
you'll see noticeable difference in the
view numbers if you um do it the other
way
oh my gosh maybe i will all right oh
somebody just said ouch don't hurt her
like that not at all i love this this is
good okay so pre-recorded is better than
live this is good to know so
is this your full-time this is your
full-time job right crypto youtube
so yeah i would say at the moment i have
three full-time jobs um
my brother and i run a production
company uh that's done very well in the
last two three years and then i started
the youtube channel because we also you
know we consult with other youtubers
that's part of like the production
company gig um
but one thing led to another and now
this channel's you know existed and it's
doing quite well so i've basically taken
most of my time away from the production
company while he's continue to run that
i'm doing the youtube channel full time
um i have a private membership on
patreon and then we also just launched a
nft platform
it's not like a marketplace like openc
or anything but it's it's a platform
that helps you
find identify and and purchase uh good
nfc deals
i see okay so before we delve into all
the nft stuff um you said you got into
the old coin market was it two years ago
uh yeah i would say yeah about so
how did you get in like what do you like
about crypto
i mean what i don't like about crypto um
i feel like you've done a really good
job articulating all this stuff
throughout you know fox cnbc all of your
channel but it's it's what everyone else
says right it's uh it's protecting you
against
burning your money with with inflation
um that's probably the first and
foremost thing i also love the
technology behind it um i think one of
the things that i like the most about
the content part of it is that it
involves technology innovation which is
something that i've always found really
fascinating um never really done it on
youtube but i've always wanted to do
something in a technology and finance
realm and so this is like a perfect
opportunity to mix content creation
finance technology all together
i don't know i mean i obviously like
when it goes up like everyone else um
but i just think it's uh it's a great
technology i think it's inevitable that
it's the future
um and this is not just bitcoin this is
you know multiple different
cryptocurrencies but
uh yeah i mean there's there's a lot to
say about it but
it's great
yeah no i hear you um but you do focus a
lot um on nfts so
let's let's go into this
where's where do you see value in nfts
i i think it's still so early that
people are having a hard time grasping
where the value is going to be and i
don't think anyone really knows where
the where it's going to end up
i think the best example i can give
because i've done gaming is if you have
played fortnite and most people watching
have probably played fortnite at least
once or understand what fortnite is in
the game it's free to play right so
anyone can play in the world which is
great but in the game there are
skins like character skins you can play
as and this is huge i mean they've had
marble characters they've had um all
different kinds of like really popular
pop culture characters in the game so
people will buy those skins and usually
they're fifteen dollars twenty dollars
and they go through they go through v
bucks but really it's twenty dollars and
i've bought personally myself probably 2
000 worth of skins in this game wow if
you just had those skins as nfts
you'd be able to own those skins and
then for example when i don't play the
game anymore like now i don't play the
game anymore
those skins are worthless now i spent 2
000 and i never get back they're in the
game and they exist but
epic games really owns those scans can
you not sell it can you you you bought
it you bought it though right but you
can't sell it nope
so i basically spent 2 000 on skins and
some of them are very rare like really
early on like i was playing this thing
before
many people were because that's the
scene i was in uh and they've gone up in
value right well they you no one knows
because there is no value on them you
can't resell them you can't really trade
them so no one really knows what the
value is but i'm saying if these were
all nfts for example
i would own them and i would be able to
resell them on the marketplace at any
time to anyone and some of them being as
rare as they are i imagine would be
worth several thousand dollars at this
point because people really want those
scans and the only way you can get them
is if you play the game super early on
for some of them
so that's like the easy example i can
give for for a number one use case uh
that's in gaming that's one area i think
it's going to be applied to to our
to uh all different kinds of areas in in
any kind of niche that you're interested
in i think there's use cases for nfts in
in many different ways another one is
coachella
is a music festival that's out here by
us
and they just came out with their own
nft collection called the infinity keys
and it's basically
a key as an nft right a digital asset
that
allows you access to go to coachella
every year for life for a lifetime you
and another guest can go every single
year for life
if you do the numbers every year if you
pay for tickets they're 500 a year
um and right you see you pay for the
ticket you go to the event you have your
fun and that's it it's over with the nft
you can do the same thing you pay for
the nft go to the event come home and
you still own the nft so you can go
again for the next 10 years if you want
to or you could sell the nft at any time
and kind of get some that money back and
potentially even get more money than you
put in
so i think like nfts have a ton of use
cases and there's no way we'd cover them
all even in even in the hour we have
um but those are like two examples that
i think are kind of
somewhat easier for for most people to
understand like this is this is the
obvious use case behind the technology
um and it turns like liabilities and and
one-time purchases into potentially
investments and assets for the long term
so i struggle with nfts um i'm not
against them at all like i'm all for it
you know let's innovate let's make
everybody's lives better let's take
ownership
um so i understand the whole in-game
asset thing for me that works i get that
right i'm also just not a gamer like
it's just not in my it's not in my bones
at all like the reason i'm here comes
from a much more political standpoint
which a lot of my um audience know
in terms of like freedom and all that
stuff um so the gaming thing i get but
it doesn't apply to me okay um but then
like the thing with the tickets
you go to a concert right and i
understand super bowl the super bowl are
doing nft tickets you go to a concert um
and then i just throw away my ticket
what you just described with coachella
sounds like a season ticket right with
like you would do a football match that
we have at home so you know you have a
season ticket you pay x amount so that
would cover x amount of seasons however
many years um but like i don't i don't
get the trading like i don't get why
would you make it into an nft i just why
would you make a ticket into an nft it
sounds like um a gimmick rather than a
real
value
okay
for the coachella example since you
brought that one up coachella sells the
ticket to me right
yeah the regular ticket uh like a like
you know one time this this year i'm
going for 500 kind of general admission
if i can't go for some reason let's say
i get sick or i just don't want to go i
could resell that ticket on like stubhub
or ebay or something like that yes
what happens then is i i sell it on step
up and i pay an outrageous amount of
fees let's just say it's a hundred
dollars worth of fees so one fifth of
the cost of the ticket is now gone right
so now i basically paid
i i only got 400 even though i paid 500
so i lost 100 and i didn't get to go
stubhub makes that money and then when
they sell it they also get a seller fee
when the person that buys it from me
they take a fee on that end as well so
that person also pays more than if i'm
selling it at the same price of 500 they
pay let's say five
580 or five you know 590 or whatever
so stubhub makes the money both times
there coachella gets nothing out of it
if it was an nft not the lifetime nft
just a regular nft pass
i have the nft that i bought from
coachella same way as the ticket but
then when i go and sell it to anyone
else
coachella gets those royalty fees and
they can set that royalty rate as
whatever they want they could be five
percent 10
right and that's still ten percent is on
the high end of what things are right
now and that's still less than the
stubhub fees who decides exactly
who decides that ten percent coachella
does or the creator in this in this case
it's coachella but it could be whoever
creates the nft right it doesn't have to
be just hotel it could be i think i've
created my own entities anyone can
create their own fts uh you know an
artist a celebrity whatever
so you create those royalty fees and
then if i sell it to someone else
coachella gets that royalty fee from the
sale
and then if that person also can't go
and they want to sell to someone else
coachella gets the rotif again
and the best part is because it's all on
the blockchain
it's super easy to do it's all digital
we can do it from anywhere in the world
so someone across the world like you
know in the uk for example
wanted to go to coachella
they could buy the ticket you know
anywhere in the world same way step up i
guess in a way but if there's a physical
ticket behind it i have to actually ship
it to them which costs money and then
stub ups got to verify that i didn't
counterfeit that ticket you know it's a
legitimate ticket all that gets wiped
away easier to do all verified by the
blockchain
it's cheaper for people and the creator
actually gets to see that royalty so
they're okay with people reselling
reselling reselling because they're
going to keep getting a kickback on that
sale no matter what the price is no
matter how many times we sold
so when you because i've i've never
minted an nft
um and so you're saying that if i submit
an nft on like open c variable whatever
it is you're saying that i can actually
choose the percentage of royalties
and i will always get paid
well okay so there's two if you're
creating an nft like your own collection
that you've you know you've put together
whether it's r or whatever
um you create the royalty fee and you
can put that in on openc on looks rare
wearable wherever
uh when you min minting
technically you can mince your own stuff
right but a lot of times what will
happen is
i'll put on a sale right a public sale
and then other people will mint
those nfts
and when they mint them um
it's variable depends on if it's like a
you know an art project or if it's
they're all if they're all the same then
it's not really that important if
they're if it's in our project where
they're each different and you want to
have rarities it's important to have
transparency that your your items are
rare and you're not like hand selecting
and favoriting who gets what so that way
you know a mint uh where you're bringing
something into existence essentially
bringing that nft into existence
uh it's important that it's it's done as
a mint and not just a
you know a transaction where i've
already minted them as a creator and
then you're just buying it off of me
it's important that you mint it so that
we can have it uh randomly generate
which one you get
right and then another thing which like
stumbles me about what you say as well
is
is the gas fees on ethereum so like yeah
somebody somebody so i i have i have
nfts i've never minted one
um
and
one of the nfts is is now worth like 3 8
or something like that and i wanted to
counter it but to counter it it cost me
money somebody put put like uh an
offering of like three i wanted to
counter it and to counter it cost me
like 200
um
which is wild
yeah so i'm like
i'm gonna i'm not gonna counter i'm just
gonna wait until i get a price that i'm
happy with and then obviously pay the
200 to sell it
especially if it's like three fourth it
doesn't matter
so okay
gas is a fun explanation because it's
very confusing uh so i understand your
frustration i mean when i first when i
first got into it there was a a project
called only force that i was going to
mint a bunch of them uh and i didn't
because the gas price was more than the
cost of the nft the gas was like 400 and
then fc was like
200. so i was like that's that's
ridiculous i'm not going to pay more in
a fee than the thing costs itself
turns out two weeks later those were
worth like forty thousand dollars so i
really should have done it
but
yeah the gas fees are a little bit
interesting it the the price of gas
changes constantly i mean i'm not sure
how familiar with how uh yeah gas works
on ethereum you do know
yeah
okay so i mean what you really want to
do
go through it
go through in case anyone watching
doesn't know
yeah so so basically
every you know every few seconds the
price of gas will change and that can
range anywhere from i've seen as low as
like 20 grey all the way up to
2 000 3 000 gray which is
insane uh and glaze is just a
denomination a very small fraction of an
ethereum so it helps you you know and
instead of point zero zero zero one it's
a hundred way for example
um so that changes constantly and that
basically changes based on how many
people are using the network at a given
time so if people are sending a lot of
money back and forth or people are
augmenting an nft uh you know the
traffic on the network goes up and then
the miners will charge you more to get
your transaction to go through quick
what you want to do when you're
in nfts uh if you're minting something
and there's a bunch of people minting it
it's usually unavoidable that gas is
going to go high and they call it gas
wars because you basically have to bid
higher gas amounts to get your
transaction to go through to be able to
get part of that mint before it sells
out
um what happens recently is that most
products are doing white lists so
they're basically hand picking people to
put on a pre-sale list so that you can
mint
at any time you want within a certain
window and that way people aren't
competing with gas to get their
transaction to go through you basically
have time whether it's six hours 24
hours to find a time when it's
convenient for you and when gas is lower
and then you can mint yours at a lower
price you know a lower gas fee so the
projects are are helping the communities
save money and gas by not fighting
against each other to get into that
project
the only thing there is that you usually
have to grind and spend a lot of time to
get on those white lists because
they hand select who they get in and
they usually want the community to be
loyal and interested in the project and
to showcase that you have to kind of
show that you're
you know active and involved in what
they're doing so
it's it's kind of a trade-off you can
instead of paying money on gas you're
paying your time to show the project
that you're worth being on the pre-sale
list that's kind of where it's gone at
the moment
but
uh if you're not minting
generally speaking i usually try to find
time like if you want to buy something
or if you want to sell something and
list something i find a time when gas is
lower um
it's completely variable sometimes there
are certain days that are a little bit
better and times of the day that are a
little bit better when a lot of people
are asleep obviously that's usually a
good time to try to do it
and i would say generally speaking right
now
anything below 100 gwei is
i would i want to say it's cheap but
it's it's it's better than it's been
six months ago 100 gray was outrageously
expensive
but now it's it's i i i infrequently
find it where it's below 100. if it's
below 100 i'm like okay i'm going to do
some transactions i'm going to do some
trades
because it doesn't doesn't go below 100
much right now it's very the scene's
extremely hot
yeah and which brings me to my next
topic um
what about competitors right so how do
you feel about solana versus ethereum
like i'm i like just before you go into
it for me personally i like the idea
that solana is of course cheaper um but
then i am concerned about like the
network switches on and off again and
decentralization and for me that's just
kind of bizarre yeah
i mean no matter what
what platform we're talking about
there's always going to be trade
trade-offs right some are better at
certain things some are better than
others solana definitely is cheaper uh
there are really no gas wars the thing i
would say that i've noticed in my time
in you know solana nitis particularly is
that
there are a lot of bots uh that can just
force
mints
and you can't i mean if you're an
average person uh
you like myself even like you really
can't compete with a bot you just can't
um
so that's that's one downside i would
say
i also think that the scene at least at
the moment
is much more uh there's a lot more
people on ethereum trading ethereum
entities
so
i would say that if you're looking for
you know some crazy you know crazy
investments or things that are really
going to blow up or things that really
have a lot of potential i haven't seen
any solana projects recently that have
done
insane are
anywhere near the numbers that ethereum
entities would do
uh that's not to say that it won't i
definitely think honestly
but why is that i just is it fast mover
advantage
partially and i just think that
i mean a lot of the projects even even
for me examples we we launched our own
nft and we had a choice you know we
could do solana we could do ethereum we
could do cardano if we really wanted to
um
it's just the most most users are on
ethereum and
i think it's really important for a
project right now to have that demand
in order to you know reach as many
people as you can
uh and so that's you know that's where a
lot of people are choosing to go as
ethereum even though there are still
obvious um
i don't know just where it's at right
now i mean if you look at the numbers
the biggest platform is openc
and they just passed a million users
and this is not even active active users
is like maybe half of that maybe like
500 000 people
total users all time that have made just
one transaction on the platform is just
past a million
so in the grand scheme of things like
that's a and it's a very small number of
people that are actually
doing this and and playing with it right
now so
you kind of need to reach those people
yeah i mean
so this is like the way i look at it i
think ethereum right now is ahead of the
game simply because it's got that first
mover advantage but
if we want to continue at this rate with
mass adoption because i think nfts have
really been the only thing which has
brought like the average person in right
um i think that's sort of the oh i think
it's very unique in that sense
but i just don't think the average
person is going to want to stay on
ethereum it's just too expensive
um so i wonder what that means for other
blockchains even like cardano
i i honestly hope that there are other
competitors that make it uh that make a
push for it because anytime you have
competition it just kind of forces
innovation to be quicker
i think whenever ethereum actually does
upgrade to 2.0 i i hope and pray that
the gas issue is less of an issue
or not an issue at all but you know how
long can we hold our breath for i don't
know
i don't know i don't know um but let's
talk about like where the value comes
from because i often find that quite
difficult like okay the whole board ape
yacht club
it goes over my head like i'm here to
talk about it but i just i wouldn't pay
for it i i just wouldn't buy it buy one
so talk to me about
where that value comes from well i mean
for board apes i don't know what the
current price is but the last time i
checked it was around 100 ethereum so
somewhere around 300 000 per per ape
which is just i mean obviously that's
that's outrageous for most people to pay
um
i i think
to be honest with you
this is i i think most people won't say
it this way people that are you know and
i'm pro i'm pro nfts all the way
obviously but i think the truth of the
matter is right now people that are in
the space that are in it so heavily
are here to make money
uh that's the truth i mean there are
tons of benefits as far as the
technology being verifiable and you know
there's collectors and there's really
cool projects that offer access to
certain groups and certain utilities but
the truth of the matter is right now i
think most people that are in it are in
it to make money ultimately whether
that's buying something like a board ape
and holding it for several years until
it goes up until you know who knows what
price
uh or just flipping things quickly i
think there are a lot of flippers in the
space right now because it is
a seller's market to be honest there's a
lot of demand coming in even though
there's not a lot of people there's a
lot of money
um
so i think a lot of people are trying to
make their money you know while they can
uh while things are hot
so i mean for a lot of people that are
getting interested i would say that
they're getting in because they say oh
my gosh you know my friend told me about
this nft that he bought and flipped it
for 20 grand in a week
that's that's money that you know it's
it's no one else is making i'm not
making i don't think most people are
making in a week in any other job other
than maybe a celebrity professional assy
athlete maybe
uh so i think that really draws people
in and then once they get in and they
realize they can make money great but
they start to realize okay there are
also other things here that are valuable
that i didn't really understand until
you get into it and it's kind of hard to
just lay it all out in one go but like i
said like there is access like coachella
um i don't know what those will end up
selling for but there's an argument to
be made that if you are a huge coachella
fan
you buy one of those nfts instead of
buying the tickets and you can go each
year there's also some other perks that
i didn't mention but
that add more value to it like you can
have 10 of your friends do a private
dinner at coachella and a vip experience
like there's little things that are
adding more value in that case
um but i think like
there are a lot of use cases for it that
people actually will find value in and
they'll meet other people that are in
those communities that can provide
further value in different ways outside
of crypto um
i mean there's there's so many things i
can go through right now but
i think i think once you get in you'll
kind of understand more okay like this
is this is where their value where the
value actually lies
so how do you navigate so like if i
wanted to start flipping nfts right
because okay
people want to make money as you said
how would i know because the thing is
at least like with old coin projects
right like you can understand who the
founders are what else they've built you
can look at the tokenomics um and then
also like you work in this space right
so for me for example somebody came to
me with a project um
and i didn't really get the use case for
it um and then like we started talking
about other things and then i was like
oh why why doesn't this sort of exchange
exist and they were like well that's
what they're building that's what
they're doing so but because i work in
this space i felt um i felt um like
a what's the word i felt like an open
market for a specific thing so i
understood that okay that would actually
be really valuable because like the
community would need something like that
with nfts like
how do you break that down okay so it's
rare what else
right i think right now the rarity thing
is like
is a big deal and i think it's not going
to be
much longer i don't know how long it'll
last for but that's that's really not a
good way to
i mean in certain circumstances sure
like think about a baseball card or a
football card or a pokemon card right
like certain cards are more rare
i don't know if you're familiar but like
certain uh like generate like addition
first edition charizards
are selling for outrageous amounts of
money right now first edition
you know yeah that's the one i had yeah
yeah
exactly
you get like so people people can
understand that to a degree i think
there's i mean there's still not a lot
of people that you know number wise that
that would trade pokemon cards still
uh as like an actual investment avenue
right like maybe
kids obviously like it's fun to play
with them and play the game and like
collect them and stuff like that but
as an adult most people would probably
okay it's you know it's a kids game
but really like the the the rarity and
the um you know scarcity of those really
rare cards
adds value to them and people are paying
you know the market has deemed them to
be valuable at this point those are 20
years old pokemon's one of the biggest
ip in the world
so that obviously adds a little bit of
you know reason for more value and in
ways that maybe these nfts are are so
new it's like how can you really say
that that's valuable when it's so brand
new
um but the truth is like they're very
similar in that way as far as for board
a for example right
at this point there are more utilities
behind it like access to this community
and access these
uh people in it that you wouldn't get if
you're not in the group but at the start
it's just a picture of a monkey
it's a profile picture collection really
it's just like you know art that some
people think are cool and some people
think is like why is this work why am i
paying money for a picture
but you can if you compare that and the
rarity of those certain things right
especially now because there's such a
staple
part like staple nft in the whole space
compare them to pokemon cards
the most rare board apes have actually
more value than the most rare pokemon
cards and i think wait let me just
internalize that wait pause that say
that again the most what
the most rare board apes are the most
expensive board apes are more expensive
than the most expensive pokemon cards
right right right at least at what the
purchase price has been
this is like this is not my opinion this
is this is market value right this is
objective uh like this is what people
have paid so i don't believe this i
haven't paid that much but someone else
has multiple people have
so the market currently values board ape
nfts more than pokemon cards i don't
think that'll last
for for eternity i think it's gonna you
know ebb and flow because it's so new
but
the point is that's where we're at right
now uh and so
the the difference between pokemon cards
and and board apes is that
nfts are so much easier to transact and
verify than traditional sports trading
cards
if i wanted to buy a charizard i'd have
to go to someone that has it
in person yeah that person might live 20
minutes away they might live
2 000 miles away or you know across the
world like and to go and buy that they
do they have to ship it to me which
they're never gonna do because it's such
an about a valuable asset i'd have to go
there
see that it's legitimate verify that
it's real
buy it you know probably have someone
that can verify it with me because i
don't know enough to verify that it's
legitimate and then purchase that in
person somehow or maybe we you know do a
bank transfer like there's this is
there's a whole ordeal if i want to buy
a board ape i go on my computer right
now click buy send the ethereum
takes 45 seconds and there we go i own
the board eight
and i don't have to worry about it being
fake or not because i can verify that
it's real on the blockchain
the the difference in they're the same
like they're very similar in what they
offer as like you know core value which
is scarcity for this example yes
but one is so much easier to transact
and verify than the other
not only that
uh the person that made board ape you
know the founders of the group every
time they're bought and sold they get
that royalty commission so they're
making money constantly every time
someone sells so they have every
incentive to make sure their product
does as well as possible because they're
going to get kickbacks from every sale
so everyone's incentivized in a way to
use the technology because it's just
it's the same thing we've had in some
ways but it's so much better than those
old traditional ways
i still think that it's niche i still
think that it's niche um
yeah there's like this idea that
everybody's in and you know but i i
don't think so i just think that like
it's a craze right now for people to
make money right so everybody's actually
going to jump onto it um but i think
once the bubble dies down um
it will become something niche like i
don't i've never i don't collect things
right what i do is hold my crypto hold
my bitcoin i don't hold anything else
like i don't trade cards yeah i don't
trade cards it's much easier you know
like yeah literally so you know i don't
trade any of those things like i can't
and i don't play
those kind of games so like i can't
relate um i'm not an artist so for me i
just
i feel kind of like
i don't say ostracized that's not the
right word but i just feel that it's
just not for someone like me
i think you are
highlighting the point that most people
are in right now um by no means am i
saying like this is this is
it's perfect it's there's a ton of
problems still like there's a lot of
things that are wrong with it still like
i said my first point on why things have
value
my opinion is that people think they can
make money on it that's just the truth
of the matter most people in the scene i
would argue are here to make money at
the moment
but i also see that there are so many
use cases that are that are really early
on that haven't been figured out the
best way to do them yet and haven't been
you know onboarding people and making it
easy for people to understand and
purchase is not there yet by any means
we are so so early in this space uh i i
my best comparison would be we are
crypto in
2014 maybe maybe 2013
uh were the internet in 1990s like it's
early it's super super super early uh
and that's why there's a lot of problems
and that's why people are able to make
money so quickly because
someone's winning big and someone's
losing big uh and the thing that's
drawing a lot of people in i think it's
not a lot of people it's maybe you know
several thousand people is that people
are seeing you can make a lot of money
quickly and who doesn't want to make
money quickly uh
at some point that will change that
narrative i think will change where
things like you know the
the foot about environmental issues and
scams um
those things will be improved like any
technology has like i mean any new
technology that comes out always has
issues to start uh until you know until
they get ironed out and it gets better
so i think it's so early that you know
these things exist and people here to
make money but at some point the use
cases behind the technology will come to
the forefront and the mainstream will
understand like
this is actually great technology this
is really helpful for whatever i'm doing
personally that i care about
and at some point that will that will
take over closure i think
i'm just going to address some of the
comments because i'm reading through
some of the comments a lot of live
comments which is cool um so some people
don't think this is live so i'd like to
confirm that this is 110 live
which is live we hadn't had a chat
beforehand we just we've literally just
met now so this is very natural
um somebody asked if i hold any nfts um
i hold two nfts one somebody actually
sent me yesterday um
and it's not a famous painter but i
can't remember it's actually a painting
that i have that i've grown up with in
my house and somebody turns into an nft
which is cool and then i hold um boss
beauties which is the one somebody sent
me um which is now worth like two point
something eth um but the funny thing is
it's like i don't wanna sell it
that's what's messed up
why don't you want to show it
i don't know i just i i don't know i
okay so i sort of feel like it's like
the fomo at the same time because it's
kind of just well you know what if it
what if it becomes a board ape huh like
i want i want that 70 each kind of vibe
like what if this will cause a warning
you know yeah
no yeah that
i i think you have a similar uh mindset
when it comes to crypto investments that
i do i i have bought and bought and
bought and bought and i haven't sold
anything ever
and i could have you know i'm like oh no
wait wait wait wait wait you've never
sold anything no well and then it's easy
yes but not in crypto you've never sold
any crypto no what do you what are you
holding if i may ask
so much uh largest is now ethereum it
was bitcoin for a while but now it's
ethereum so bitcoin ethereum cardano
uh solana
i hold a lot of actually i hold a lot of
luna
i don't know if you are a lunafan know
about luna yeah i know about luna um i i
heard it i heard it's very good the
tokidomix is what i've heard it's very
good one the stable coin it burns every
time you use it and yeah
that yeah i'm on the on the train that
uh at some point usdt and maybe even uh
usdc
will not be accepted as much as they are
now because they're centralized entities
and if people really believe in the
decentralization of stable coins that us
terra
is one of the options that may take over
so for that reason i'm i'm a big
believer in luna um another one that
that's much like a really really really
small altcoin is is omi
um omi omi
yeah and it's the the cryptocurrency
behind vv which is a nft platform
that is much more geared towards um it's
i think it's a lot easier to get into as
a platform than the mainstream ethereum
type stuff so you guys can check that
out if you want to i'm not going to give
you a whole rant on it but i'm a big
believer in that as well they have
disney and marvel ip on that with their
nfts because they've actually licensed
it from those companies so
i think those will be huge at some point
um and then probably like 15 other
altcoins
wow and you've never sold one
no well i mean i did sell some at a loss
for tax purposes but okay uh like very
very small amounts
that's wild that's absolutely crazy um
let's talk let's talk mass adoption um
how do you how do you see things going
from here right so like it's kind of
unclear what kind of market we're in i'd
still say we're in a bull market
certainly um
nfts are still booming um nfts have been
i think
a great form of mass adoption one of the
best forms we've ever seen um
there's also like a lot of regulation
coming the us is quite hostile right now
so how do you see this space developing
from here
for nfts or for crypto or both
both yeah both you can start with nfts
um
well i mean one thing i've actually
noticed is that when crypto does well
nfts
the volume gets dried up
i see people are going back and forth
um so
truthfully my one of my strategies right
now is to start playing into that
because i've seen it twice happened
twice now pretty well correlated both
times when crypto runs
uh nfts start to the floor start to
dwindle quickly
and that's usually i mean from
historically i've seen it's a good good
time to buy in potentially and then vice
versa when you know when nfts are hot is
when crypto is like when crypto had that
decline from november to
now i guess roughly uh that's nfts have
been on the up and up and then like
really peaked i would say like two weeks
ago and you can see that on google
trends you can see that on floor prices
across the market like it's correlated
quite well
now that eath and bitcoin are starting
to move again a little bit i'm seeing
some floors drop pretty drastically on
nft so
um i think they're like inversely
correlated so i'm gonna try to play into
that a little bit but overall i i
i have a lot of opium with with crypto
so it's like i i want us to believe in a
bull market
uh i was a firm believer in a lot of
people that i watch
that the end of 2021 would be similar to
the 2017 uh blow off top
where we had like a really big run and a
peak obviously that did not happen
uh or maybe it did if you think that you
know 64 000 or maybe 69 000 was the peak
then maybe it did happen already i don't
think that's the peak i think we still
have more room to run as far as the
build market goes
but because i've gotten so ingrained in
nfts
my day-to-day like worry and care and
looking at the prices of all other
crypto has gone to like zero
i kind of just check in every once in a
while to see like if there are major
movements for for what i might expect to
happen in nfts
but i'm playing the nft game right now
and like i said i haven't sold anything
in crypto so my my plan is just told
that the technology the base case the
foundation the fundamentals behind all
the technology in my opinion hasn't
changed whether there's regulation that
you know negatively impacts it probably
will happen at some point
uh i just think that where we're going
is is going to be far greater than any
kind of timing i can do right now so
i'm just going to let it ride
and with nfc zen i know obviously you're
bullish on the whole idea of play to
earn
um
trading cards
but once everything does die down um
where do you see
where do you how do you see them being
adopted do you think
you know it's going to be music
like what's the main use case going to
be just like just as a side point just
to say it sort of reminds me of twitter
actually because when twitter first came
about it was like this mainstream
platform right it was like snapchat
facebook whatever it was now it's like
really fun and niche which is like in
more like intellectual news conversation
you know it's not it's not tick tock
right it's for it's for a little it's
for an older crowd who want to have
different types of conversations so
where do you see nfts going
um
in turn okay just just in general i feel
like
you prefaced it with twitter which is an
interesting uh comparison but yeah i i
mean i think i think what will happen is
if the crypto bull market does continue
and we do see like some crazy run
um and it you know continues to be a
cycle in some degree
then i think we're gonna see a really
rough time in nfts
uh and maybe even if crypto doesn't run
we'll see that that period i just think
i mean if you compare it to any you know
like bitcoin for example
after it goes crazy hot there's gonna be
a period where it comes back down and
people think it's just a fad people
think it's just a you know
get get rich quick scheme or something
like that i think that still has to
happen
um
or on the flip side
mainstream businesses
find a way to
uh make it really easy for people to get
into nfts because it's not easy right
now it's very it's very time consuming
it's very confusing there's way too many
moving parts there's way too many uh
abilities for people to get scammed and
there's there's a lot to it right now
so i don't think it's it's easily ready
for mainstream adoption
that has to happen whether that happens
soon
or not i don't know uh it really depends
on what you know like for example
mastercard i think or visa
i think has teamed up with coinbase to
try to allow people to buy nfts with
credit cards which would be a huge
on-ramp if they if they paired with
coinbase as well because it's publicly
traded i think that's a huge
differentiator between coinbase you know
and their nft platform they're coming
out and something like openc
um i think people have a lot more trust
in coinbase than they do with these
other you know other up and coming
platforms
so if they pair with a major credit card
company to allow people to buy
nfts on ethereum through a credit card
or debit card
that people already trust that would be
a huge uh catalyst for where things are
going to keep going
and then maybe we won't see an nfc
bear market per se
but if that doesn't happen i really do
think we're gonna have a period where
it's gonna get ugly most projects will
go to
basically zero or you know stop
uh stop doing what they're doing because
it's just you know no one's using it
anymore
but at the same time the ones that and
we call them blue chips but it's hard to
say blue chip because it's only been
like
eight months for most of these projects
but
the blue chip projects i do think if you
can buy them
at that you know that low that low in
the in the market
i think people are going to make a
fortune if you can find the right ones
and i don't know what those are i'll be
trying to figure it out but yeah
i mean that's just everything in this
market isn't it like that's just
everything with even if it's like with
you know what's the next meme coin
what's the next yeah i mean if you find
it if you play it right you you know you
absolutely can make a lot of money but
you're gonna have a lot of failures in
trying to find the right one i'm sure i
i personally have i've tried a couple
different ones and i'm like you know
what i'll just put a little bit of money
in there and who knows if it goes crazy
great if it goes to zero
it goes to zero like that's that's yeah
i'm gonna take on some small small small
amounts
yeah i think that's what i always say i
always say like the best thing to do is
never to okay obviously never afford
more you can afford to lose and actually
but also um it's not just that it's also
like sometimes you're gonna have to wait
a while i feel this way about bitcoin
right like
for me bitcoin will always recover like
i'm just like forever bullish on bitcoin
it always recovers you have to be
be able to afford patience like you have
to be able to financially afford
patients and wait um but yeah that's my
thing with nfts a lot of them will go to
xero just like many altcoin projects so
i'm just very hesitant and i think it's
about finding
that value
which i'm not 100 sure what it is long
term just yet
i i don't know i don't know if i have
the answer either i think there are a
lot of i think there will be use cases
for most
niches
i just don't know what those will be
yet like what the the prevalent and and
useful most useful
uh mass adopted ones will be i think
play to earn is an easy example that i
think is already
somewhat obvious uh and that will be
what what is the biggest thing for
gaming to start i think there
there are so many other things like
there's there there are uh guilds where
you can
own entity assets that are
playable in the games and then rent
those out to like esports organizations
or
you know communities or players and that
will be a business in itself it's
already happening but i think that'll
happen to me much like i think esports
organizations in the future will be that
that was what they'll be they'll be like
they'll own a bunch of really valuable
in-game assets that they allow their
players or their community to use or
rent out and that's their business model
i think that's gonna happen i just go
that just like defeats the whole purpose
though right because then like you don't
own it anymore the company owns it which
i think is like one of the issues with
with crypto because like
we're trying so hard to you know create
decentralization but then like these
major companies come in these you know
these web three vc kind of companies
come in and start centralizing the whole
damn thing um which one right well
so okay so i don't when i say companies
i mean i don't mean like the game
companies i mean like
uh no companies
right companies though but
that's that you you they'll own it if
they want to and they can rent it to you
if you want or you can buy it yourself
like you don't have to have yeah but
what if they buy it all up and then it's
too difficult well i mean they're not
going to buy all of them it's coming you
know i really think so i really i really
do think so i think it's like i think
it's like a catch-22 like we fight so
hard to to um you know
regain our
you know sovereignty over whatever the
hell it is whether it's money assets
in-game assets
but i i do think that
they will come in i mean i'm sort of
seeing this slowly i mean and that's why
i know like a lot of bitcoin is kind of
uncomfortable with web3 because
it's not what it's supposed to be but
we'll see we'll see i just hope things
can stay decentralized i've seen i've
seen the conversation a couple times uh
i i will say we'll see what happens i
don't personally think that well i mean
it will be an issue to some degree like
they will definitely own a good stake in
the in the game per se
but there's no way that they're going to
own or be able to afford to own
everything
uh if that does happen
i imagine that the market will find a
way to make it so that it's not you know
that it's not basically what we're
trying to fight against which is which
is centralization and you know
monopoly essentially uh of the space i
just don't think that will happen
but like i know i shouldn't i know i
shouldn't say this so i'll like whisper
it quietly um but like for example
michael sailor right um microstrategy
buying up lots of bitcoin
imagine just imagine i'm not saying they
are at this point at all but like what
happens if like all these major
institutions because they can afford to
end up buying up all the bitcoin right
and then the only way we can get more of
a cut is through like some form of
bitcoin etf or some kind of
you know share and micro strategy and
then you don't actually own the actual
bitcoin you just own a share and a
company that owns bitcoin like grayscale
bitcoin trust or whatever i don't know
i'm just i'm always i'm watching what's
happening um and yeah
i mean uh
the answer is don't sell your bitcoin
there you go that's your answer
or wait so long enough until they're
they're you know they make the market
price and then you have to ask for an
unreasonable amount of money to sell it
yeah
but that that obviously favors the
people that are in early and not the
mainstream that we are you know trying
to potentially get on board to
understand like the benefits of this
right defeats the benefits if if
if you know if someone owns all of it or
most of it
i agree with that
yeah i just like get to be early
it is good to be early i just don't uh
well i don't know we'll see we'll see
what happens i mean you could be right
that could be an issue i never really
thought about it that way but
i just think there'd have to be a lot
i mean it had to be a lot of people that
are willing to sell to the same
handful of companies i guess
yeah i don't know i'll have to see how
it plays out um
it's weird i i'm like i'm seeing how
everything's going um
but like i'm i'm here for it i'm trying
to learn um you know i really appreciate
um all the nft content that you put out
there because i'm still trying to
navigate it and i would like to get more
involved um somehow someway so i'll
figure that out um but matt where can
people
find your content how can they follow
you
uh so on youtube it's just matt's crypto
just like the name right down here
there it is there it is boom um yeah
matt's crypto and then on on twitter
it's just matt cabuzio
do you have any um final thoughts that
you want to say
i'm uh i'm excited uh i think regardless
of you know the ebb and flow and the ups
and downs that's going to happen no
matter what uh i think
crypto and nfts have a long way to go
and i obviously
we're both on the same boat that we
think they're going to go to a better
place than they are now a more
mainstream place
so i'm excited about it uh i would just
say you know if you are getting an nfts
uh obviously i have a bunch of content
on my channel you can watch but i would
say also like do your own research look
at other people's channels learn as much
as you can what i tell all my people in
my private community is spend 15 hours
watching and participating as if you're
going to actually buy certain things but
don't actually buy anything yet so you
can kind of learn like hey this would
have panned out really well or i would
have lost all of my money because i was
totally wrong about this idea that i
thought was gonna be really good and it
wasn't um i know from experience if you
hop right in
you're gonna you're gonna make failures
you're to lose money it's going to
happen so if you kind of pretend like
you're in
and play the game a little bit before
you actually spend your money you'll
probably avoid a lot of those mistakes
so just you know
try to learn about it i think i think if
you learn about it now this year at all
you're going to be so early you're going
to thank yourself later on that's what i
think personally so
yeah i tend to take it yeah i tend to
take a similar opinion um but matt i
want to thank you so much for coming on
it's been so great speaking with you
yeah i appreciate it thanks for having
me
yeah for sure and guys thank you so much
for tuning in the comments have been
really funny i've been um watching them
as as we've been chatting so thank you
guys so much for tuning in um and i will
see you all next week bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]